let's say I have some subspace V that is
a subset of RN that is a subset of RN
and let's say we also have its
orthogonal complement so we write that
as V perp that'll also be a subset of RN
now a couple of videos ago it might have
even been the last video if I remember
properly we learned that the dimension
the dimension of V plus the dimension of
our orthogonal complement of V which is
also another subspace is going to be
equal to N and remember dimension is
just the number of vectors you need to
have the number of linearly independent
vectors you need to have a basis for V
and the dimension here is the number of
linearly independent vectors you need to
have a basis for the orthogonal
complement of V now given this let's see
if we can come up with some other
interesting ways in which these two
subspaces relate to each other or how
they might relate to all of the vectors
in RN so the first question is do these
guys have n do these two subspaces have
anything in common are there any vectors
that are in common with two and to test
the the whether there is let's just
assume there is and see what the
properties of that vector would have to
be let's assume let's assume right here
that I have some vector X but I have
some vector X that is a member of my
subspace V let's also assume that X is a
member of the orthogonal complement of V
so X is a member of the orthogonal
complement of V now what does the second
statement mean membership in the
orthogonal complement means it meet well
let me write it this way this means that
X dot V for any or any V that is a
member of our subspace is going to be
equal to 0 let me write it this way
actually XV is equal to 0
for any or any V that is a member of our
subspace that's what it means to be a
member of these orthogonal complement
now
now we assume that X is also a member of
V so that means that we can stick X here
as well right for any member of V X is
also a member of V so that implies that
implies that X dot X is equal to zero or
another way to write that is that the
length of X the length of x squared is
equal to zero or the length of X is
equal to zero and that's only true for
one vector you can even try it out with
the different constituents of X that's
going to the only vector that that's
true for is the zero vector so X has to
be equal to zero vector that's the only
vector in RN that when you dot it with
itself you get zero or who's the square
of its length is equal to zero and we've
shown that many many many videos ago so
what this tells us is that the
intersection the intersection between V
and V complement this kind of
upside-down u just means intersection it
just means where do these two sets
overlap the only place that these
overlap is with the subset of the zero
vector so if I were to draw all of RN
like this so if I were to draw all of RN
let's say that this is RN let's say
that's RN and let's say I draw the
subspace V the subspace V let's say it
looks like this and let's say I draw
this this is V my subspace B and let's
say I draw the orthogonal complement to
V let's say it's all of these vectors
right here let's say this is the
orthogonal complement to V right there
so this is V perp these are all of the
vectors for which if I take any vector
or these are all of the vectors that
when I dot it with any vector here I'm
going to get equal to zero so this is V
perp and the intersection they're
overlap the only vector that is a member
of both the only vector that is a member
of both right there is the zero vector
that's their only intersection so that's
fair enough the only vector that's a
member of a subspace and it's orthogonal
complement is the zero vector nothing
too profound there let's see if we can
come up with some other interesting
relations between the subspace and it's
orthogonal
maybe some arbitrary vectors in RN so
let's just let's just write down well we
know that the dimension let's say the
dimension of the dimension of our
subspace V is equal to K let's say it's
equal to K if it's equal to K we know
that it's dimension plus this orthogonal
complement has to be equal to n because
we're dealing in RN let me write this V
is a subset of RN and we also know that
the orthogonal complement of V is a
subset of RN I drew it right here the
dimension of V is equal to K that's a K
right there then what's the dimension
what's the dimension what's the
dimension of the orthogonal complement
of V going to be well when you add them
together I wrote that up here they have
to equal n so this guy's going to have
to be n minus K right if you have K here
this guy's dimension is K this guy's
dimension right here if it's n minus K
then when you add these two up k plus n
minus K is going to be equal to n so
this guy will have a dimension of n
minus K now what does dimension means it
means that that's the number of linearly
independent vectors you need to form a
basis so let's say that I have K vectors
as a basis for V so let's say I have v1
v2 all the way to VK and this is and
this is a basis basis for V which just
means they're all linearly independent
and they span V any member of V right
here can be represented as a linear
combination of these vectors there
enough now the bate the dimension of the
the orthogonal complement of V is n
minus K so we could have n minus K
vectors let's call them let's call them
W 1 W 2 all the way to W n minus K we
have n minus K of these characters and
this is a this is a this set is a basis
this is a basis
for the orthogonal complement of V so
any vector in here can be represented as
a linear combination of these guys right
here and all of these guys are linearly
independent so you don't have any
redundant vectors there if you will now
let's explore
let's explore now I'll tell you where
I'm trying to go I'm trying to see if I
combine these two sets whether I get a
basis for all of our n that's where I'm
trying what I'm trying to understand so
let's just let's just look at let's just
say that let's say that for some for
some constants C 1 and let me write it
this way so for some constants c1 times
v1 plus c2 times v2 plus all the way to
CK times VK plus plus for the constants
on these guys I'll use D plus d1 times
w1 plus d2 times w2 all the way to plus
D n minus K times the vector the basis
vector W n minus K let's say that I'm
curious about setting this sum equal to
0 equaling the equaling of the zero
vector for some scalars right the
scalars are the C's and these DS for
some scalars and we know that there's at
least one solution set of scalars for
which is this true we could multiply you
know all of these constants C 1 C 2 CK D
1 D 2 all the way to DN minus K they
could all be 0 or there might be more
than one solution in fact if they if the
only solution if the only solution is
that all of these constants have to be
equal 0 then we know that all of these
vectors are linearly independent with
respect to each other and if they're all
linearly independent with respect to
each other then we know well I'll touch
on that at the end of the video we know
that they'll be they could be a basis
for RN but we don't know that yet we
don't know that the only solution to
this is all of the constants being equal
to 0 so let's see if we can experiment
with this a little bit if we take this
equation which I just wrote down we know
that one solution is all of the
constants the C
these equal to zero but we don't know
that that's the only one let's just
subtract all of the W vectors from both
sides of this equation so what are we
going to get we're going to get c1 v1
plus c2 v2 all the way to plus CK VK
we're going to subtract this from both
sides of the equation it's going to be
equal to the zero vector which is really
just zero I don't even have to write it
down but maybe I'll write it down there
just to see you understand I'm just
taking this this equation I'm
subtracting these guys from both sides
so zero vector minus d1 w1 plus d2 w2
plus all the way to D n minus K W n
minus K this is and I could just Dahl I
did as I subtracted these terms right
here from both sides of this equation
and I could I don't even have to write
this a zero here that's a bit redundant
so what I have here is I have some
combination of the basis vectors of V
right so if I want to if I if I look at
this this is some linear combination of
the basis vectors and B and V so this if
I call this a vector let me call this
let me call this some vector X let's say
X is equal to c1 v1 plus c2 v2 all the
way to CK all the way to CK VK we know
that it's a linear combination of our
basis vectors of V so X is a member X is
a member of V by definition any linear
combination of the basis vectors for
subspace is going to be a member of that
subspace well similarly what do we have
on the right-hand side of this equation
on the right-hand side of this equation
I have I have some linear combination of
the basis vectors of V complement right
so this right here this right here and
you could put just put a minus all along
that but that won't change the fact that
this is some linear combination this is
some linear combination some
linear combination of of V complements
basis vectors basis vectors so this
vector over here is going to be a member
of let me call this this could be some
other vector what we're going to be
equal to each other so we could also
call this X so X is equal to this but
it's also going to be equal to this and
since it can be represented as a linear
combination of the compla or the
orthogonal complement of these basis
vectors or V perp basis vectors we know
that this also has to be a member of V
perp let me just review this because it
can be a little bit confusing I just set
up this equation right here we know that
there's at least one solution all of the
constants equaling 0 anyone could do
this now I subtracted all of the yellow
terms from both sides and I got this
equality the left-hand side of this
equality is linear combinations of the
basis vectors of V so any linear
combinations of the basis vectors of B
is going to be of the basis vectors of V
is going to be a member of V that's the
definition of basis vectors so if I set
X equaling to this left-hand side so if
I say X is equal to this left-hand side
I can say that X is a member V well if X
is equal to the left-hand side it's also
equal to the right-hand side for the
right-hand side is some linear
combination of V perps or the orthogonal
complement of these basis vectors which
tells us that X is also a member of V
perp but what does that mean that means
that means that X must be equal to 0 I
just showed you the beginning of the
video the only vector that's a member of
a subspace and its complement is the 0
vector so we know that because these are
orthogonal complements or at least be
purposely orthogonal complement of V we
know that X must be equal to 0 we know
that X must be equal to 0 so if X is
equal to 0 let's write this down here X
is equal to 0 so we just we just
rearrange
so we know zeros has to equal these both
of these sides of the equation and these
are the
constants that we had to begin with but
what do we know about these two sets let
me let me write this a little bit neater
let me erase this so that I can just
write the zero vector right there so we
know that the zero vector has to be
equal to this that's the only that's the
only vector in RN that sets a member
both of V and of the orthogonal
complement of V now this is a zero
vector and we have this linear
combination of V being equal being set
equaling to the zero vector now what do
we know what these cut about these
constants what does C 1 C 2 all the way
to CK have to be we know we know that v1
through v4 V that tells us that they
span V and that they are linearly
independent linearly independent linear
independence by definition means that
the only solution to this equation right
here the only solution to this equation
right here is that all of the constants
have to be 0 so the fet linear
independence tells us that C 1 C 2 all
the way through C K must be 0
must be 0 so all of these guys right
here are 0 which is the same as all of
these guys all of these guys must be 0
now let's look at the right-hand side of
this equation we could put the minus all
the way but the same argument holds this
linear combination of V perps basis
vectors is equal to 0 the only solution
to this because because each of these W
ones W 2's and W and minus KS are
linearly independent the only solution
to this being equal to 0 is all of the
constants have to be equal to 0 that
falls out of linearly linear
independence you could just multiply
this if this negative is confusing a bit
if it makes it look different than that
you could just multiply this negative
out and say oh well those would be other
content B minus d1 would have to be
equal to 0 minus d2 would have to be 0
minus DN minus K would have to be 0 but
it's the exact same argument linear
independence which falls out of the fact
that this is a basis set
applies it the only solution to this
being equal to zero is each of the
constants being equal to zero well that
means that D 1 D 2 all the way to D n
minus K must be 0 now let's go back to
what I wrote up here this was the
original equation that we were
experimenting with just manipulating
this equation a bit and understanding
that the only intersection between V and
V perp is a zero vector and that linear
independence means that the only you
only have linear independence if the
only solution to this is equal to the
only solution to these vectors equal to
0 is all of their constants equal to 0
then we know that all of these terms c1
through CK D 1 through D n minus K they
all have to be equal to 0 that's the
only solution to this larger equation
that I wrote up here well the only
solution to this large equation that I
wrote up here is that all of the
constants are equal to 0 that implies
all of this implies that if I were to
take the set right here of v1 v2 all the
way to V K and I were to augment that
with the basis vectors of V perp which
are w1 1 do that in a different color W
1 W 2 all the way to W n minus K that
this is a linearly independent set
linearly independent set and I know that
because the only solution to this
equation is each of these constants
having to be equal to 0
that's what linear independence means
this implies this linear independence
linear independence implies that we used
the fact that linear independence
implies that all of these equals 0 to
get the fact that c1 was all the way the
CK was equal to 0 we've got this right
here and then we use it again when we
set this thing also being equal to the 0
vector we knew that all of the DS had to
be equal to 0 I don't know if you
remember the 0 vector came out from the
fact that that was the only vector that
is a member of both sets
and I'm being a little bit repetitive
but I really want you all to understand
that this proof isn't some type of you
know circular proof that we just wrote
this equation we wondered about what the
solution set is to it we rearranged it
we said hey both sides of this equation
our members are members of both V and V
perp the only the only vector that's a
member of both is the zero vector so
both of these sides of the equation have
to be equal to zero the only solution to
that is eat all of these constants being
equal to zero because each of these are
linearly independent sets so therefore
all of these constants have to be equal
to zero and then this augmented set
where if you combined all of the basis
vectors that that is going to be
linearly independent now many many many
many many videos ago we learned that if
we have some subspace some subspace
space with dimension with dimension n
and we have and we have n vectors that
are n let me write it this way and
linearly independent vectors that are
members of your subspace that are
members of your subspace then those n
linearly independent vectors than those
n vectors or the set of your n vectors
let me write that a little bit those the
set of those n vectors is a basis for
the subspace for the subspace now RN is
a subspace RN is a subspace of itself RN
is a n-dimensional subspace and
dimensional subspace or it is an
n-dimensional subspace we could write
the dimension of RN is equal to n now we
have n linearly independent vectors in
RN so that tells us that these guys
right here are a basis
they are a basis for RN or RN we have n
linearly independent vectors right we
have n minus K that are coming from V
perp and we have n that are coming from
V from their basis or from their the
basis for those subspaces so now we have
a total of n vectors they're linearly
independent they're all members of RN so
they are a basis for RN which tells us
that any vector in RN can be represented
by linear combinations of these guys
which is fascinating so this tells us so
this is a basis for RN so that tells us
that we can take any vector let's say
let's say a is a member of RN some
vector that means since this is a basis
for RN that a can be represented to some
linear combination of all of these guys
so it can be represented as you know c1
times v1 plus c2 times v2 plus all the
way to plus CK times VK and then let me
use a different letter just to make sure
that you understand that this is a
different equation that I'm writing that
I wrote earlier in the video so I could
write this and then I can have some
other constants let's say plus I don't
know e 1 times our V perp basis vector 1
plus e 2 times this guy plus all the way
to e and minus K times the N minus K
basis vector for B perp I can represent
any vector in RN this way or another way
to say it
what is this what is this right here
this is some vector this is some vector
that is a member of our subspace V and
then this is some vector over here let
me write it as X that is a member of the
orthogonal complement of V right this is
just a linear combination of the perps
basis vectors this is just a linear
combination of these basis vectors so
given that all of these characters given
that all of these characters are our
basis for RN tells us that any member of
RN can be represented
linear combination of them but that
means that any any member of RN can be
represented as the sum of a member of
our subspace V plus a member of your
subspace V perp this is a member of V
and this is a member of V perp and
that's a really really interesting idea
you give me a subspace you give me a
subspace u and then we can figure out
its orthogonal complement any other
vector any other vector in RN in RN can
be represented as a combination or sum
of some vector in our subspace and some
vector in its orthogonal complement now
the next question you might be asking is
this representation unique so is this
unique is that is this unique right here
this representation well let's test it
out let's test it out by assuming it's
not unique let's assume that it's not
unique assume not unique so that means
that I have so for some vector a that is
a member of RN I could represent it two
ways I could represent it as equalling
some member of my subspace V plus some
member of of the orthogonal complement
of V I could represent it that way or I
could represent it as some other member
of my subspace V plus some other member
of my orthogonal complement the X is so
x1 x2 are members of V perp and then v1
and v2 are members of V so if we assume
it's not unique there's two ways that I
could do this and I'm representing it as
these two vectors now clearly this side
of this equation is equal to that these
are both representations of a so we can
rearrange this a little bit we could say
that v1 minus v2 if I subtract V 2 from
both sides I get v1 minus v2 is equal to
is equal to if that's subtracting v2
from both sides and if I subtract X 1
from both sides it's equal to x2
- - x1 right now if I subtract these are
both these are both members of the
subspace V and any subspace is closed
under addition which is an subtraction
which is really just you know call most
a special case of addition so if this is
a member so v1 you know this this vector
right here the vector v1 let me write it
this way let me call my some vector Z
being equal to both of these guys which
are equal to each other
Z is the vector v1 minus v2 any subspace
is closed under addition so if you take
the difference of two vectors in the
Subspace it's if you take two vectors
you find their difference in a subspace
then that the resulting difference is
also going to be in the subspace so this
so Z is going to be a member of our
subspace V and then this vector right
here which is also the same thing we
just set that to be equal to our vector
Z this thing right here is going to be a
member of week of our V perp Y because
both X's both x1 and x2 are members of
of the subspace V's orthogonal
complement and that is a subspace as
well this is a subspace so it is closed
under addition and subtraction so this
it is also going to be a member of your
subspace so we could also say that Z is
a member of the perp or the orthogonal
complement of V well we've done this
multiple times this was the first thing
we showed in the video the only vector
that is a member of a subspace and it's
orthogonal complement is the zero vector
so Z has to be equal to the zero vector
so this is equal to the zero vector well
if these both of these are equal to the
zero vector we know that v1 minus v2 is
equal to the zero vector which implies
that v1 must be equal to v2 and we also
know that x2 minus x1 is equal to the
zero vector or x2 is equal to x1 so we
stride to say that hey there's two ways
to construct some arbitrary vector a
that's an RN and we set it that equal
and we wrote that down but then we found
out that no v1 must be
equal to V 2 and X 1 must be equal to X
2 so there's only a unique way to write
any member of RN as a sum of a vector
that's in our subspace V and a vector
that is in the orthogonal complement of
V